This video is presented by fistula bourbon
From human thumb, Joss Wheaton,
the man responsible for Buffy the Avengers and the Snyder cut
comes the groundbreaking Saifai series that got canceled,
but like traditionally canceled,
not just weekend canceled Firefly returned
to a tie when studios weren't catering to a nerds, every women fantasy. In fact,
they couldn't even be bothered to air this stuff in order and explore a budget.
Really riff on star Wars, not playing anymore.
Anybody makes so much.
Here.
A 20 group of heroic rebels fought a war for independence against the Alliance,
which I'm sure was fought over planet's rights or something.
Maybe don't think too hard about the whole Confederacy and space thing.
I'm thinking will rise again, uh,
suit up and your dustiest Browns in pages with a crew of the serenity,
a that looks like an up gizmo dog. There's Malcolm Reynolds,
the captain who's quick on the draw and even quicker to lose his temper.
If we can get to that bridge, are you going to get us back on our feet?
We'll keep a civil time in that mouth around. So it's shucked gag her.
If you have to the wandering about remembering, well,
stick it back in your crate, shut up. Feel bad.
He makes everybody cry like a monster.
Jane, a white trash star screen cat nine are out.
Calling the shots. I'm in interrupting charge here.
And I'm telling you how it works.
I guess that makes me that's a concept to wrap your head
around.
Simon, a cup of plain yogurt. Who's super into his sister. My sister.
Who's a genius. She was a gift.
I don't think my last act in this versus going to be betraying my sister.
Shepherd book, who wasn't always a shepherd. You know.
Now how would a shepherd know a name like that? And we'll look at these wounds.
I'd say 54, our sniper rifle.
We do a lot of shooting at the Abbey there shepherd one day.
You're going to tell us all how a preacher knows so much about crime,
that it was shepherd.
Allen today as himself.
Oh dear God. No.
And if you were wondering if there were any female characters, come on,
this is a Wieden show. The ship has every kind of jaws woman,
the sexy fighting one. Okay.
People, if it moves.
Shooting, the sexy adorkable was.
That's the buffet table. Well, how can we be sure unless we question it.
The sexy, sexy one.
Most of my clientele is male. Do.
You know that?
And the sexy living weapon with a brain of a child who just woke up from a
nightmare because you do seem a little.
River.
You know, it's a shame. This got canceled after one season,
we'll know which one has a barren room. Do you like quippy dialogue?
Then you're in luck because if this falls under 50 quips in hour,
it's rig to explode,
strap it in with nonstop banter that would make Kevin Smith and Diablo Cody's
noses bleed,
and then cheer on the talented cast that makes it worth turning every type of
possible. Quit into television gold like sarcastic quips.
I always hoped you. Two kids would get together. Who is she?
Snarky. Quips. Thank you. You can stoop.
To be in alone while you wash it. First sassy quips.
That sounds like something out of science fiction. You live in a spaceship.
And the old Josh Wieden three-step. So when makes a statement,
something contradicts that statement. Funny reaction.
Don't ever let them know where you are.
They won't discover it till they go on to the next round of drinks way.
Good drinker. That one. We're going back.
Oh, that's a spicy of weed and climb a board serenity for plenty of action and
mayhem. As the crew takes the job. What are we doing? Oh, crime hopes.
The ship doesn't fall apart. You'll have enough to buy.
Your own ship better one than this piece of crap.
Whatever you enter this or talk junker.
You paid money for this sir on purpose. What do you mean.
River pools? A weird can kill you with my brain mal uh,
flirts with an aura.
They teach you that in horror Academy. Well,
I don't suppose you're the only hard.
That day. Someone mentions the war.
What were you in the war Wars over for some that won't ever be fought in the war
together, right? So I'm on board here. for the independence.
I love the fact that you two are old army buddies and you have wacky stories.
The job goes South and everyone draws their guns.
Someone gets almost dead now.
Yep. He's dead.
And someone says something to Mel.
He dramatically turns and repeats it to himself.
We've got good. I call it a swim. Right?
And you know what it works. I can give about the show. Oh, I want one.
Look to that, man. Summarized.
Next thing I know I've got a Brown coat and the Gorham officially licensed
monopoly game. So walk the verse for a spell with Firefly.
The show that laid the groundwork for so much of today's pop culture,
including how to throw tantrums.
If they ever tried to take our stuff away again,
but ironically owes its legacy to being taken off the air too soon,
because let's face it on a long enough timeline.
Every fan would have gone full river. Eventually first season of Firefly,
it was fine. I guess seasons two through five nuts.
A much Nathan feeling really needs to do something new,
like a quirky crime procedural.
What exactly are you supposed to be?
Space cowboy story. James T quirk.
Alan Zilles extraordinary punch list. Jane and hats.
Princess Leia. Zoe spacial Hill.
[Inaudible].
Go Ram it Jim. I'm a doctor. Not a space. Ravine, Leeloo,
Rutten, no rubble.
No running way. Oh, run away. You're running full
lasers. Where's my money. My sister's brain was running playground.
Zac Efron, Gorham, something, something.
[Inaudible] respond to this. We need some core. I'm here to support. 10 is
[inaudible]. If you have a good go around
where you think you're not my grandma on my grandma ship. Shiny. You look
shiny. Katherine, where a shiny hat, shiny presence
, shiny, shiny, shiny, shiny, shiny, shiny.
Goods and cargo. The.
Goods must be attacked.
This girl is a smallest cargo I've ever had to transport. It was damaged goods.
Anyhow, Jane helped with the cargo cargo cargo, cargo goods, cargo,
cargo goods, cargo cargo, Chinese stuff.
[inaudible].
Chinese people with speaking roles.
Now she's my wife. Are you getting my wife into trouble?
I'm not flying anywhere without my wife.
Could you please tell my wife the fun she's missing out on?
Everything's laid out. If you'd like to cook for your husband.
And welcome to the rough Dax, secondhand roughnecks,
just in space.
Okay. This is what you were trying to make. Let's see what you did.
Couldn't get a hold of no flour. So it's mostly protein.
This video is presented by fiscal the bourbon. It ain't just a bourbon.
It's a festival. I smoked my stove, cheese anywhere.
I want person, woman, man,
camera TV. Oh man. I shot Marvin in the face.
He's just standing there menacingly.